Tucker Carlson and Don lemon's cable
news ousting and just how ugly things
could get
I've been told that Bo
OT Brian Friedman to negotiate their
exits he's famously aggressive he's
represented people like Megan Kelly in
the past listen I don't look CNN pays
you well
Don reportedly has around 20 million
dollars left on his contract which was
set to expire in three years it's
unclear if CNN intends to pay him out
meanwhile it's estimated Tucker earns
upwards of 20 million dollars a year and
recently signed a multi-year deal you
know nothing is permanent except our own
demise but Tucker is also facing a
lawsuit from one of his former producers
Abby grossberg I reached a breaking
point where the harassment was so bad
grossberg alleges she was bullied and
subject to anti-semitic comments while
working on Tucker Carlson tonight Fox
News calls the lawsuit quote
unmeritorious if someone makes a claim
there's only one question is the claim
true or not as for Don there's
speculation this contentious interview
last week with GOP Presidential
candidate Vivek ramashwamy left CNN
Executives exasperated and the Second
Amendment please I cannot keep a thought
if you guys are talking to me in my ear
so hang on one second at one point he
snapped at producers while co-anchor
Poppy Harlow appeared visibly
uncomfortable have you ever woken up the
next morning and felt like maybe I went
too far
yeah yeah
but if I didn't then I didn't do my job
this morning poppy joined Caitlin
Collins for their first broadcast as a
duo we wish him the best yeah we
certainly do and you know late night
went all in it's easy to make jokes
about Tucker being gone but now who's
going to tell me which Eminem is most
woke you know
[Music]